we have just eight more days till we're
back to hell Sabrina fans in the latest
trailer for part three has just dropped
so we're gonna take a deep dive to
figure out what exactly is in store for
us this season and explore just how the
hell oh my puns are terrible Sabrina
will save Nick a few days ago we got a
music video trailer that also had some
fresh new clips from the season so if
you haven't seen my breakdown for that
check it out in the link in the
description and just a reminder before
we get started I'll have a huge part
three ending explained and part four
theory video coming out shortly after
the release so make sure to LIKE and
subscribe so you'll be notified as soon
as it comes out so let's get into it our
first shot is of the welcome to
Greendale sign which we've seen in
previous seasons but what sets this one
apart is the procession of vehicles in
the top right now I think this is the
arrival of the carnival will see some
more shots of this later on in the
trailer but one of the storylines in
part 3 centers around a tribe of pagans
looking to resurrect an ancient evil and
what's cooler than a group of pagan
carnies it's hard to make out here but
we have Sabrina in front of a painting
of what appears to be a castle next to
the sea this most likely takes place at
Dorian Gray's bar which we saw last
season which you can tell by matching
the wallpaper we also know later on in
the trailer Dorian makes an appearance
so it's likely Sabrina has to get him
out of the painting but more importantly
here is the voiceover of Lucifer her
father who says she must claim the
throne of Hell in order to save both
Greendale and her boyfriend Nick scratch
of course this has other implications
since Lucifer is trapped within Nick's
body it's likely that if Nick were to be
saved so too would Lucifer here we have
Lilith formerly miss ward well in a shot
we saw briefly in the music video
trailer Lilith has taken over as queen
of Hell as we can see by our crown but
this will be short-lived as a new
contender Prince Caliban will be
introduced in a bit now this is a very
interesting shot Harvey has his arm
around Roz they're even holding hands
but check out the background not only
our Ambrose and prudence holding hands
but it appears they're all at the witch
Academy mortals in the witch Academy
unheard of but judging how everyone is
happy here this seems to be after
they've had some
a victory we get a recycled Sean of Nick
imprisoned which we saw in the last
trailer as it cuts to Sabrina's eyes
turning crimson red now when you combine
this with Lucifer's voiceover
proclaiming what she must do it's likely
Sabrina here is either being given a
vision of what's happening now or in the
future or this is allowing her to talk
to Nick which I'll get to in a bit the
main story this season is all about
Sabrina having to go to hell in take
over as Queen but as we'll uncover later
on in the trailer there are plenty of
obstacles in her way some more shots
here of the denizens of Hell judging by
their attire this seems to be some sort
of High Court but this is really what I
want to talk about the robe and platinum
hair suggests this is Sabrina ready to
take on her role as Queen and if you see
right before it cuts all the members of
Hell are getting ready to kneel and here
is Prince Caliban the new villain of
part 3 since Lucifer is trapped in
lilith has gotten what she wants aka
being the queen of hell the show needs a
new antagonist he is a prince of hell
sculpted from the clay of pandemonium
pandemonium being the capital of hell so
it's likely all these shots take place
here Sabrina is having night terrors
which the editing suggests she's been
visited by either Caliban or this dude
it's also possible this creature could
be connected to the ancient evil the
pagans are trying to resurrect which I
lean more towards that than it being
Lucifer as we'll get into some more
clues of this later on the next few
shots center around Sabrina and Baxter
hi Roz and Harvey are concerned that
this whole hell thing is starting to
take its toll on Sabrina but she says
it's not hell it's Nick we see Sabrina
in front of the gate of hell in the
Greendale minds with Harvey behind her
it seems as though she's found a way to
open the gate but it doesn't work if
Sabrina is gonna get to Hell she'll need
to find another way in and I've heard a
few sources say there is a backdoor to
Hell which will come into play this
season another shot of our imprison Nick
which in my last video I suggested this
red cape here is Sabrina's this is
followed by another shot from the music
video trailer of these bodies hung up
like scarecrows in the other trailer we
know Roz Harvey Theo and Sabrina make it
here which might be some sort of
purgatory or limbo but notice the Raven
I can't help but think this could
possibly be Lily's familiar stolen
keeping an eye on Sabrina in the gang
even though stola swooz killed earlier
on with Lilith being the queen of Hell
it's entirely possible he could be
brought back in some way and it's even
more evidence that the next shot is of
Lilith as Queen likely before she is
usurped by Caliban the voice-over here
also comes from an older adult male
possibly Blackwood but I'm not sold on
it he proclaims that the worlds of
heaven hell and earth are off balance
it's only until Sabrina takes her
rightful place as queen of Hell that
balance will be restored will later get
a shot of Lucifer who also tells Sabrina
that being queen is her destiny which
she needs to embrace here we have
Sabrina in this beautiful white dress
with a crown of flowers a fitting chains
since you'll soon be wearing a crown of
bones it looks as though this is her
first time meeting the pagan carnies now
I also got a big Midsummer vibe here I
won't spoil that movie but it does
involve pagans who have weird ceremonies
during the summer solstice plus they all
wear white in that movie just like our
characters do here leading me to believe
this part of the season deals with the
summer solstice and it looks like it
would line up with the show the
beginning of part two started with the
winter solstice and progressed into
spring so having part three occur during
the summer is totally within the realm
of possibility teleporting Sabrina now
correct me if I'm wrong but we've never
seen Sabrina teleport in this manner
before and the flames suggest she's
arriving from Hell with some bad [ __ ]
happening at the Spellman's the clock
that falls here does so at exactly
midnight we get this shot of Sabrina
tour des crying perhaps thinking about
Nick as it cuts to this ancient tome the
hands here are definitely not Sabrina's
my guess is that this is someone from
Hell who help Sabrina give her
information she needs to save Nick and I
can't help but think that these three
characters in the drawings are
indicative of Lucifer Lilith and Sabrina
we have this shot of Lilith beside the
throne and if you look closely her crown
is off to the side could this be right
around the time she's d throned and
here's our first shot of cheerleader
Sabrina so it looks like she's not only
queen of Hell but has time for
extracurriculars she tells this unknown
figure that Hell is under new management
which is totally a Sabrina thing to say
we have this shot of Sabrina unveiling
herself under this
loke which matches her meeting with
Caliban which we saw earlier she has a
blue cape here instead of red could this
be because her red one is with Nick we
have this young chap using his nails to
write in blood I will not bite my nails
over and over again on the chalkboard
it seems we may be going to some sort of
demon orphanage or limbo or purgatory
especially since the next clip is of
another child getting his hand sliced
off this is one of the coolest shots of
the trailer Sabrina in this desolate
wasteland skulls on sticks and a cross
in the distant background but what I'm
more curious about is what Sabrina is
holding here now it's too covered to
tell but it's likely being brought out
to this cross now there's a big fake out
here Ambrose asked Sabrina if she wants
to do this as we cut to Sabrina in a
different outfit saying can you help me
it's more likely she's asking someone
else that says I believe Ambrose for
much of this season will have a separate
storyline with prudence revolving around
fighting Lord Blackwood this is about a
shot with prudence displaying her dual
blades with Roz and new character Robin
in the back with the red cap according
to his character description released
online he's described as a romantic
interest for theo who has an elfish
quality is a mischief-maker
and arrives with a carnival and is
potentially dangerous judging by this
photo he's decided to side with the
witches but we can't count out a
betrayal notice also roses shirt the
Fright Club which is the name of the
band she's in with Harvey Anthea which
we saw in a music video trailer this
shot also suggests that prudence Roz and
Robin come to save the witches from the
pagans or it could potentially be Lord
Blackwood we have this quick shot of
theö Roz and Harvey and judging by the
background it looks like they make it to
hell now this shot looks like it could
be Robin perhaps this is the dangerous
aspect the description was talking about
either way it seems to be one of the
pagans with his body being taken over by
plants some cool cutting here as we get
this circular ceremony here paired up
with the cheerleaders in a circle and
could that be Ross in the middle we now
have a new character Mambo Marie a
voodoo practitioner who appears to be
working her magic at the witch Academy
we saw Ambrose and prudence enlist her
help in the music video trailer and it
just so happens we see them getting hot
and heavy in the next clip and it could
have something to do with
in performing their own ceremony judging
by this weird doll and candles in the
other trailer we get a better glimpse of
it here we have Caliban putting on the
crown as king of hell with members of
the High Court celebrating he tells
Sabrina if she wants the crown she'll
need to prove it and she punches that
crown right off his smug face aunt Zelda
scold Sabrina saying being queen of Hell
isn't a summer job and that her seeing
Nik puts the coven in danger this is
followed by a few shots we've seen
before of the pagans arriving at the
witch Academy followed by Sabrina
visiting nits now the thing that has me
Nick scratching my head here is that
this doesn't look like hell more like
the dungeons of the witch Academy and
perhaps it is and they need to keep Nick
chained up surrounded by what seems to
be a circle of salt for his own
protection and to keep Lucifer at bay
until they can find a way to save them
for good here we have what appears to be
they satanic Church and two of our
witches who you may not remember from
previous seasons elspeth and melvin who
seem to have a bigger role this season
they are visited by Lucifer in his goat
form but just how exactly this is
possible is still not certain here we
have Nick telling Sabrina to forget
about him notice how everything is red
could this be what she's seeing here the
pagans arrive in front of the witches
and I'm wondering if this is supposed to
be some sort of peace offering or shared
meal between the two rather than the
pagans interrupting them here's that
shot confirming Dorian Gray is back in
this Spellman's calling upon some higher
power perhaps for help against the
pagans now we have our first shot of
Theo and Robin on a ferris wheel looking
like they're on a date the red cap is
really unusual plus he's wearing it at
night so he's likely hiding something
underneath there Sabrina kisses Nick
perhaps a goodbye kiss before she goes
on her final adventure and I think this
also confirms that's her red cape here's
a quick shot of some hands from Hell
banging on the table but that figure in
the top right looks a lot like what
Lucifer was wearing last season we don't
know who this person is but it seems
like someone bowing to either Lilith or
Sabrina but our next shot tells us a lot
we have Lilith off to the side as
Sabrina is being prepared to be queen is
this what we saw her wearing earlier
here we have the three wise demons on
pretty sure happy and taunting Lilith
who's just been overthrown as queen of
how
I think it's a great dynamic that Lilith
who is one of the main antagonists the
last two seasons against Sabrina is now
teaming up with her this is a pretty
cool shot and I wonder if this is that
back door to hell that's been teased
here's our only shot of Salem so far we
still don't know if he'll talk yet but
it looks like we're near the carnival
judging by these flyers and this shot
here of Sabrina unleashing a world of
pain to this pagan near the carousel we
have our first look this season of the
return of Lord Blackwood with a totally
new look as I theorized in the last
trailer he spent most of his time in the
Shetland Islands of Scotland and who is
that behind him it's a bit hard to tell
but it looks like Agatha one of the
weird sisters the next shot also happens
to be heard tied up in a straightjacket
here we have Nick having escaped his
confines beating up this bearded man who
we haven't met yet
followed by Lucifer vomiting out a ton
of beetles
here's Hilda using a puppet like a
voodoo doll to contort this unknown
woman followed by miss ward well being
choked by vines remember that the real
body of Wardwell was returned to normal
last season when lilith left her take a
look at this foot here stepping on what
appears to be a metallic step like you'd
find on a carnival ride I'm guessing
this is the same creature we saw at the
beginning and this is what the pagans
are trying to resurrect and also what's
causing the choking for Wardwell oh and
a great shot here of Sabrina Nick
escaping hell followed by the doors to
its main entrance closing as they try to
escape it looks like Sabrina will make
it out but it's too close to say if Nick
does as well the last shot is of aunt
Zelda hiding Sabrina on her exploits in
purgatory and hell even hinting what's
next heaven and judging by how he'll
centric this season seems to be I wonder
if that's where we'll be going will this
season tie into angels in a battle
between heaven and hell I can't wait for
this upcoming season so make sure you
like and subscribe to stay tuned when I
come out with my big part 3 ending
explain video and part 4 theories I want
to hear your thoughts about what might
happen in the comments below and feel
free to follow me on Twitter for more
updates at things story YT until next
time remember hell's under new
management
I'm the devil